Let's take stock of where you are.
You start with a graph G, from G,
you can construct its Laplacian, L of G.
Now, suppose you have a partition of G,
that implies the petitioning
of the vertices into two sets,
call them V+ or V-.
In linear algebraic terms,
you can translate this vortex
partition into a partition vector.
Each vertex i is assigned
to one partition or
the other designated by a +1 or -1.
Now suppose you want to know
the number of cut edges in G.
Then you can count it algebraically.
That suggests that partitioning could
be viewed as choosing an X to minimize
this quantity.
So this becomes a common
notarial optimization problem.
Formally we want an x that minimizes
the number of cut edges subject to two
conditions.
First you want to assign every vertex
to one partition or the other and
you want the same number of
vertices in each partition.
This problem is
unfortunately NP-Complete.
Rats!
So to work around that,
let's relax the problem a little.
Let's start by taking away
the requirement that we assign exactly
a +1 or -1 to every vertex.
If you do so, then there's
a really neat fact we can use.
This fact combines everything we know
about Graph Laplacians, along with a
cool theorem from linear algebra called
the Courant-Fisher Minimax Theorem.
If we're allowed to use any vector y,
where y is normalized in a certain
way and it's elements sum to 0,
then the vector y that minimizes
this quantity is actually q1.
Q1, you'll remember,
is the eigenvector corresponding
to the second smallest eigenvalue.
And in fact the minimum value simplifies
to something that is proportional to
that eigenvalue.
So what does this mean?
Let's go back to the original
optimization problem.
Our most recent fact tells us that the
optimal value is at least this quantity.
To turn all this into an algorithm
you need one more idea.
Choosing x to be q1 give us a lower
bound on the thing we want.
But how do we take a q1, and
actually turn it into something
that is a partition vector.
In other words, something that has plus
or minus 1 values in all the entries?
Do you remember our spring analogy?
In fact, the Laplacian derived from
the spring system gives us a second
smallest eigenvector
that looks like this.
If you plot the components
of the eigenvector for
the second smallest eigenvalue,
you get something that looks like this.
It's sine curvy,
because that's what the fundamental
modes of the spring system look like.
And as it turns out,
half of its elements are positive, and
the other half are negative.
So that suggests
the following algorithm.
First, compute the Laplacian for
the graph.
Then compute its second
smallest eigen pair.
Then determine the partition
using the sines of
the components of the eigenvector.
So, that was a lot of work, but
the final algorithm is very compact.
And indeed for plainer algorithms
it works really, really well.
Here are two examples of what the
spectral partitioning algorithm produces
on two graphs.
Hey.
Someone should make
a t-shirt out of these.